for the dog are you telling me that it's
825 Marty has a watch what time do you
think it was when he was visiting Doc
Brown's garage he clearly can't blame
his lateness on the silly clock
experiment mountain duet clearly already
knows that marty is on the back of the
Jeep but reacts to it again like he's
noticing him for the first time further
down the road also Mountain Dew hat hail
valley is a small town but they support
every American's right to sit in the
theater and watch a porno movie 24 hours
a day right there in the town square
also orgy American style hey man when
it's an orgy I don't think anyone's
instilled with the sense of nationalism
it's really hard to believe that the
bully Biff entered the same line of work
as nerdy George McFly and ended up being
a supervisor three pins to make George
look extra nerdy in this shot two pens
to make him look 1/3 less nerdy in the
next shot brother mom thanks Dave for
clearing up the relationship between
your uncle and your mother this grand
appearance by Doc Brown and his DeLorean
is pretty great but it's also unlikely
considering that the DeLorean has these
vertical opening doors it would have
been impossible for doc to get into the
car while it was in the truck so he
would have had to use his remote to get
the car out of the truck get into the
car on the outside drive it back into
the truck and then just for the purpose
of impressing Marty drive it back out
but he's not even doing it to impress
Marty because he doesn't even know he's
here yet why are these flames on the
road that are clearly touching doc and
Marty not burning them Einstein could
see the Libyan national bus at a great
distance and they didn't even have their
headlights on yeah I'm with you doc
maybe they could have tracked you down
to Hill Valley but how did they figure
out to go to Twin Pines mall at 1:30 in
the morning to come find you
when Einstein made his time-travel
journey the DeLorean was super icy when
Marty makes his there's no ice on the
car also he drove through the open door
of the barn meaning his car should be
facing away from the Peabody's when they
come to investigate and even if he came
from another direction there appears to
be no openings behind the car inky black
of night to early morning sunrise in a
matter of seconds and then it's a
totally sunny day in absolutely no time
a phone book listing does not prove
whether someone is dead or alive it's a
good thing Lou doesn't take a look at
the money Marty gives him he might find
some years that don't exist yet
John F Kennedy obviously the road didn't
exist in 1955 and it's obviously one of
those haha back in 1955 people didn't
know how famous John F Kennedy would be
type of jokes but Marty's grandfather
says who the hell is John F Kennedy as
if you're supposed to be familiar with
the name of anyone a road is named after
Marty clearly didn't have the camera on
when Doc said this even though
apparently it's possible for this camera
to be wired to a 1955 TV I still have
trouble believing that there would be a
perfect playback after one of these
plugs falls out of the camera this is
cool and all but why would Dave's head
be missing while Marty and Linda get to
keep everything and why just his head
not his whole body and wouldn't the
pictures very existence start to
disappear
George's rouille awakened by some Eddie
Van Halen somehow doesn't make a noise
to wake his parents up this kid on the
left looks like he's helping Marty break
his friends soapbox scooter in this shot
but his calmly watching everything from
his own scooter in the next shot geez a
new Biff was a bully but not like a
homicidal dude that's your mom although
it's a young Lea Thompson so I don't
know if I can blame you
Wow even in 1955 you could open
something locked as long as you had
something straight in metal the most
telegraph punch in history somehow lands
on Viv's face he deserved it but damn
the punch George tried to through
earlier was it nearly as telegraphed and
he stopped that one perfectly fine it's
actually kind of amazing after George
sock Biff that this redheaded stepchild
comes in and steals Loraine from him
after the adrenaline rush of beating up
the biggest bully in school who's gonna
stop you now this is actually a great
scene in one of my favorites in movie
history but since we know George is
gonna come back and push this dumbass
off the rein and we know he's gonna kiss
her why would Marty's existence still be
in danger does George have to kiss
Lorraine at the exact moment he did in
the first timeline Marty doesn't do
anything to help George make this
decision George makes the decision on
his own so this would have happened no
matter what suddenly Marvin is excited
about doing another number with Marty
even though he screwed up most of Earth
angel
[Applause]
all of Chuck Berry's contributions to
rock and roll are now explained his
cousin saw a white guy playing Johnny be
good and he took all the credit
during Marty's awesome guitar solo I
started wondering what happened at the
Pepsi box that this amplifier was
standing on earlier in the evening
Strickland has his ears covered at the
end of Marty's solo and takes his hands
away but apparently just the thought of
Marty's guitar skills makes him cover
his ears again but you decided to name
your first son Dave anyway but don't
worry that's just movie time you're
giving yourself 10 minutes to tell doc
he's gonna get shot why not an hour or a
day as long as you don't run into
yourself you should be fine also says 10
minutes and enters 11 minutes that's
cheating
car suddenly goes dead when you most
need it cliche electricity is way slower
than I thought it was man Doc Brown can
take a lightning strike like no one I've
ever seen
geez how many things does this car have
to crash into before it shows any damage
whatsoever
is that former mayor red Thomas on the
park bench he looked kind of old back in
1955 and in 30 years of past its thing
shouldn't it be like the old won't be
dead by now car suddenly goes off just
hit the steering wheel with your head
Marty that worked last time here's
another thing Marty's time-travel
adventure affected the Libyan national
bus now has their headlights on that's
just chaos theory working its magic so
Marty starts making a run for it
considering what we've seen in this
movie so far the hill valley town square
is probably a little more than two miles
away from them all but non-athletic
slacker Marty can somehow make that trip
on foot in ten minutes okay so he took
the precaution of wearing a bulletproof
vest which probably shouldn't have
worked against an ak-47 at that range
anyway but he didn't change anything
else the location or time where he would
be shot or stealing plutonium from the
Libyan Nationals in the first place you
think that in 30 years he might have
come up with another power source for
his DeLorean anyway which brings us to
this point in the movie the whole living
room is different from what Marty
remembers which probably means a lot of
things Marty remembers never happened
and his whole life would be different
yet his other self is still apparently
the same guy with the same experiences
who still hangs out with Doc Brown and
finds himself in a time machine going
back to 1955 it's arguable the whole
world would be different since he
interacted with a lot of people and not
just his parents
it's also arguable you know
to keep time-travel simple or else you
lose your entire audience and you don't
become the biggest hit of 1985 still a
sin we never said we were happy about
that yeah what do you want that Dave
Marty I always wear a suit to the office
and you still live with your parents
[Music]
nobody asks Marty why he thought the car
was wrecked when he clearly wasn't
furthermore the new Marty apparently
owns the 4x4 that he wanted so much in
the beginning of the movie wouldn't
someone in his family say hey Marty it
doesn't matter if the car is wrecked
anyway you have a 4x4 in the garage let
this be a lesson kids when you punch a
bully that believe becomes a total
later okay so it's understandable that
in the movie they don't acknowledge that
Marty looks a hell of a lot like the guy
that helped them get together 30 years
ago they may have done it when he was
growing up they may have forgotten what
1955 Marty looked like but you can't
just give all the credit to freakin Biff
for your marriage this big yellow truck
is completely gone from the driveway all
of a sudden and your girlfriend turns
into Elisabeth Shue and your dad is
completely unrecognizable you don't have
to go back to 2015 to fix things right
can't you just tell them in 1985 so
they'll remember lady or give them an
envelope they can't open until 2015 well
last night he sure did about 288 in like
no time
[Music]
[Applause]
that that that that the the the the
she's a real nutcase you hang around
with him you're gonna end up in big
trouble
oh yes sir son your ego is writing
checks your body can't cash Tommy us
beeping Tommy a thing
[Applause]
[Music]
you like you enjoy something news
artist something kid yeah I'd like a keg
of beer please you don't say yeah ah how
much is that hearing ID Sonny
give me a keg of beer and nice